marche en avant régulateurs à celle une
autre stagiaire jours pour tout savoir
sur la mécanique avec deux autres
comparses
ils apprennent les rudiments du
maniement de cette vieille dame de 101
ans et chacun est à son poste
mécanicien conducteur agents de
manoeuvre est chauffeur un stage de
trois jours entre parce que nous on m'a
offert ce stage pour un anniversaire et
on me l'a offert parce que j'aime les
trains je suis passionné de trains
depuis pas mal d'années et c'était quand
même une occasion de conduire une côté
valeurs parce que je pense pas que ça
soit le quotidien de beaucoup de gens
au-delà du fait de conduire les petits
trains à longueur d'année l'agent
conduit un grand un vrai c'est ça
l'association du chemin de fer de riez
organise ce genre de stage depuis 25 ans
l'ambition est de transmettre non
seulement une passion les en savoir
faire un temps mobile et dans les années
70 les loco à vapeur disparu ensuite
dans les années 90 2000 les gens qui
connaissaient aux disparus mais nous
nous avons eu la chance dans les années
70 80 et s'y intéresser de rencontrer
des gens d'anciens cheminots de
récupérer des données vous plaît s'il
vous plaît
alors on y va
jean devra passer de nombreuses heures
derrière la chaudière pour être
conducteur habilité en train vapeur mais
l'essentiel est de mettre les mains dans
la grèce et du mais l'odeur du charbon
le temps d'un stage